actors Cole Sprouse and Haley Lou
Richardson have some pretty amazing
on-screen chemistry we love their
performance and five feet apart so much
so that we're taking a sneak peek at
some of their cutest behind the scene
moments watch until the end to find out
which cast member Haley can't seem to
get enough of am i right you're not
wrong you think that's cute
do you think it's cute fans couldn't
believe their ears when they found out
that cole sprouse will be taking the
role of will newman in five feet apart
the actor who is best known for playing
duck head dawns on Riverdale's
quickly became chummy with his co-star
Haley Liu Richardson Cole and Haley are
now friends who know how to make the
most out of a sad situation just look at
how comfortable they are together Cole
posted this picture on his Instagram
claiming that he and Haley are taking
some song requests and the hilarious duo
were quick to joke around on the set of
their photo shoot it's easy to see that
: Haley lucked out in the looks
department but that's never stopped them
from broadcasting some of their worst
angles to make light of their
heartbreaking roles the actors posted
this hilarious behind the scenes selfie
proving they're just like everyone else
when actors are working on a big
production like 5 feet apart it's only
normal for them to have to wake up with
the Sun and from the looks of things
Haley isn't much of a morning person
which is why director Justin Baldoni
chose to heckle his lead actress with a
surprise video
[Laughter]
this little clip goes to show just how
close the movies cast members have grown
to be this hilarious behind-the-scenes
moment was filmed at 5:45 a.m. but Haley
still managed to be a good sport about
it five feet apart premiered on March 7
2019 in Los Angeles the stars walk down
the red carpet before celebrating their
newest achievements as many of you know
Cole and his girlfriend Lili Reinhardt
who plays Betty Cooper on Riverdale
aren't too fond of PDA but that didn't
stop Lily from giving Cole a sweet peck
on the cheek while on the red carpet
Haley was up to no good which comes as
no surprise just look at what she did to
her co-star while posing for a high
profile picture real mature Haley but
super hilarious nonetheless this brings
us to our next behind-the-scenes moment
which showcases the star celebrating for
more reasons than one this was an extra
special day for Haley who is also
celebrating her 24th birthday
they cast surprised her with a cake and
Cole squeezed her shoulders as she blew
out her candles five feet apart is a
movie that will undoubtedly have its
fans sobbing in their seats so it's nice
to know that the cast managed to keep
things light and happy behind the scenes
instead of letting her character's
predicaments get to her head Haley chose
to be herself whenever her hectic
filming schedule allowed it just look at
her prancing around while the movie's
director laughs and walks away she's got
some killer dance moves which is why it
comes as no surprise that Haley used to
be a competitive dancer we couldn't help
but crack a smile after witnessing this
adorable backstage moment actress
Kimberley Herbert Gregory who plays the
role of nurse barb quickly got on
Haley's dancing train and believe it or
not
so did Justin Baldoni here we see just
how comfortable the cast is with each
other despite having a tight filming
schedule to follow the actors know how
important it is to have fun and they
have loads of it keep watching to find
out which actors might have had a little
too much fun on set if you haven't
noticed it already Haley is a huge Joker
she loves to laugh dance and make light
of a dark situation in this scene we see
Haley walking in front of the camera
with a morose look on her face but when
she gets behind the camera her mask
comes off so to speak seconds later we
see Cole emerge from the sidelines
only to have Haley's head poked back
into the shot it's obvious that
he's on super good terms with the person
behind the camera Hailey's goofiness is
one of the many reasons people love to
work with her you would think that
filming a movie about cystic fibrosis
would result in a dismal
behind-the-scenes real but that's the
last thing the movies cast wanted
instead of making a film about the
horrors of this terrible genetic
disorder the Cache chose to highlight
how those suffering from this disease
could still live a happy life thanks to
modern medicine my lungs are dosed okay
can you just let me enjoy this view
while I can here we see the cast
gathered around a dining table while
preparing for a scene everyone is
laughing and having a good time it's no
secret that Halley and Justin Baldoni
are super close in fact we initially
thought that they were more than friends
when we first saw this behind-the-scenes
moment because well we couldn't help but
notice that Halley was brushing and
leaning her hat on Justin's shoulder we
mean just look at her face
she seems to be in a state of total
admiration and can we blame her this is
Justin Baldoni we're talking about
Dustin is well known for playing Rafael
Solano on the hit TV series Jane the
Virgin the actor has been interested in
directing ever since he could remember
and he knows better than anyone how
important it is to have a connection
with your cast so while it looks like
Haley is giving just in the eyes if you
know what we mean she's actually just
hanging out with her longtime friend
Haley's fiance is none other than Brett
Dyer who played the role of Michael
Cordero jr. on Jane the virgin brat and
Justin go way back and are no strangers
to adorable behind-the-scenes moments so
it makes sense that Halley and Justin
have a friendlier relationship than most
directors care to have with their actors
we love how close Cole Justin Halley and
the entire crew got to each other while
filming five feet apart before you go
let us know which backstage moments made
you smile from ear to ear give this
video a big thumbs up if you love Cole
Sprouse and don't forget to subscribe to
the things to catch all of our newest
videos thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]